las calles del casco antiguo de nablue
parece la entrada de un museo los
habitantes a menudo adolescentes se
amontonan para visitar la casa de wadi
al agua antiguo jefe de la guardia de
los Leones un nuevo grupo armado fue
asesinado por las fuerzas israelíes aquí
mismo salvo las bóvedas centenarias todo
está destruido el tío de wadía al agua
recibe a Los visitantes y describe al
detalle la compleja operación israelí
escuchó un ruido afuera abrió la ventana
para ver que estaba pasando entonces
entró un dron y empezó a dispararles al
lanzar municiones
el dron disparaba y después ellos
lanzaron una especie de misil desde ese
lado luego solo hubo enfrentamientos en
el suelo varios muchachos fueron heridos
[Música]
trató de practicar los primeros auxilios
pero el dron siguió disparándoles y fue
asesinado justo ahí
otros dos miembros de los Leones fueron
asesinados esa misma noche desde
entonces algunos se han rendido y otros
han sido detenidos según los parientes
de algunos de los miembros el movimiento
apenas empieza los leones han hecho
mucho por proteger la ciudad y brindarle
seguridad por eso el grupo se ha
desarrollado tan rápido puedo decirles
que va a seguir Esto va a durar está
lejos de ser el fin como piensan algunos
o como lo que dicen los israelíes
si los leones son tan populares en parte
porque rechazan el control de las
facciones políticas palestinas sus
miembros reivindican varios ataques
contra soldados israelíes desde entonces
se han creado otros grupos armados
siguiendo el mismo modelo
hoy algunos miembros de los Leones
marchan junto a los milicianos de la
brigada balata último de los grupos
armados de nablu en haberse constituido
los militantes entierran a uno de los
suyos magdiash de 15 años Fue asesinado
a la víspera durante unos
enfrentamientos con las fuerzas
israelíes A las afueras del campo
está brigada se constituyó el septiembre
pasado su jefe y fundador se hace llamar
sancaloni y apenas tiene 22 años de los
cuales ha pasado varios en prisión
afirma que su grupo cuenta con unos 40
miembros y que tiene una ausencia total
de agenda política solo importa la lucha
armada inmediata la brigada balata
protege el campo y no está afiliada a
ningún partido somos jóvenes
revolucionarios y no hay una decisión
política detrás de nuestra existencia
si por ejemplo yo estuviera afiliado al
fatal necesitaríamos una decisión
política para luchar o para disparar
y otra decisión política para dejar de
disparar no queremos eso queremos
mantener el poder de decisión en
nuestras manos lo que dice mandá es
absurdo prohíbe disparar a los israelíes
pues no no está prohibido cualquier
colono puede entrar a nablus y disparar
a la casa del gobernador y el gobernador
no tendrá derecho a hacer nada aparte de
cerrar sus ventanas y dormir incluso
Aunque una bala impacte en su casa no
tiene sentido
para él la autoridad Palestina hace
parte del problema Empezando por su
presidente mahmu davás elegido
inicialmente para un mandato de 4 años
pero en el poder hace 17
el presidente no es Legítimo
el Gobierno palestino ya no es Legítimo
se moverán de sus sitios No claro
los hijos de los ministros viven en el
lujo no saben lo que pasa en nablus en
tulcarem o en cualquier otra ciudad y
les da igual
estudian en el extranjero en
universidades prestigiosas mientras
nosotros nos educamos en las escuelas de
la ONU y Con todo el respeto que le
tengo a las escuelas de la ONU
honestamente no se puede decir que sean
lujosas pues estén bien equipadas
queremos vivir con dignidad
El joven miliciano dice que no quiere
morir
sin embargo sabe que es probable que
algún día su rostro esté junto a los de
aquellos que son celebrados como
Mártires en el campo
según llama el tiragüi este ciclo es
inevitable como miembro de fatah y líder
poderoso en el campo de balata conoce
bien a Esta generación que se ha
incorporado a la lucha armada
la mayoría de los jóvenes que se han
unido a esas brigadas como la guardia de
los Leones la de yenim o la de balata
rondan la veintena nacieron después de
los acuerdos de oslo
25 28 años después de esas negociaciones
de paz después de ese proceso de oslo
ven que no ha habido ningún avance hacia
una solución política eso es lo que se
refleja en su reacción
la naturaleza le tiene horror al vacío
esos grupos cualquiera que sea su nombre
han surgido para llenar ese vacío
presente en la sociedad Palestina
El Triunfo de la extrema derecha israelí
en las últimas elecciones le preocupa
dice que es un gobierno de guerra y que
la situación irá de mal en peor